good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today his SCP 31 object
class safe special containment
procedures SCP 31 is to be contained in
a standard humanoid containment chamber
the humanoid section is actually
stricken from the document located in
site-77 s safe SCP wing personnel
interacting with SCP 31 are not to view
it directly and communicate with test
subjects through an intercom system
installed in each chamber the
containment chamber is to be cleaned
once per week my custodial staff wearing
opaque goggles to mitigate SCP 31's
effect description SCP 31 is an
amorphous organism with a mass of 75
kilograms as CP 31 is able to move at a
pace of 3 kilometers per hour and leaves
a trail of oil when it moves it is only
capable of rudimentary physical movement
testing of recovered tissue samples has
shown that SCP 31 is at least partially
composed of human muscle and epidermal
tissue as CP 31 is capable of
reproducing human speech in any pitch or
tone although it is not currently known
how a CP 30 one's biology produces them
subjects directly perceiving a CP 31
will see it as an individual the
subjects knew and had a romantic
attraction to at some point in their
past when made aware that it is being
observed as he P 31 will claim to be
this person and that they have been left
destitute by some event in their past as
CP 31 will use this to attempt to
persuade the subject to allow it to stay
with them for an extended period of time
until it is able to return to a stable
situation this effect applies to all
persons who view as CP 31 and research
has not determined an upper limit to the
number of persons who can be
did buy a CP 31 at the same time after
inspecting the residence as CP 31 may
attempt to start a romantic relationship
with the subject and if successful and
will begin living in their home several
cases have been documented where a CP 31
began to actively affect more than one
subject at a time eventually having a
nest containing between at least
eighteen different hotel rooms
containing subjects with some former
relation to a CP 31 as CP 31 was
recovered following contradictory police
reports taken after a riot and multiple
subjects reported wildly contradictory
views about SCP 31 s appearance and
initial civilian units were also
affected however wide distribution of
amnestics and inhaled tranquilizers
pacified all affected subjects at mobile
task force size 7 was able to recover a
CB 31 from the condemned hotel it had
taken residence in as of November 16th
1958 SCP 31 has been classified safe
addendum research has determined that a
romantic subjects are not affected by
SCP 31 however all of these subjects
will report a CP 31 as being a small
plump humanoid figure with specific
features being obscured by dark smoke
emanating around the entity in the shape
of SCP 31 s body further testing is
required to explain this phenomenon
further testing has shown that the
perception of subjects affected by SCP
1937 is similarly affected
this was a short lecture today but thank
you for listening you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre best ship
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]